one of the biggest mysteries in
archaeology happened toward the end of
the 13th century here in southwestern
Colorado these spectacular villages
built along the edges of cliffs are what
remain of an ancient population that
simply vanished for decades
archeologists have been trying to
decipher why these people abruptly
abandoned their homes and what became of
them known now as the ancestral Pueblo
these prehistoric farmers settled in the
Four Corners area of the United States
around 600 AD and they thrived there for
nearly seven centuries around 1200 they
started building villages and caves
along the face of cliffs some of the
biggest and best preserved that these
dwellings are found in Mesa Verde
National Park in Colorado which draws a
half million visitors a year who come to
marvel at these precariously placed
homes archaeologist Donna Glowacki of
Notre Dame University is one of the
researchers investigating what happened
to the people who build these villages
as well as why they were built in the
first place when people start moving
into these alcoves it's not that long
after a really very difficult drought
period and actually the alcoves are
somewhat closer to some of the major
water sources that people had in this
area it's also a little bit difficult to
get to them and so there's some
protection there's protection against
the elements and the wind but there's
also protection against other people
studies of skeletons from across this
region show that rates of violence were
increasing around that time an
architectural evidence indicates that
Pueblo Society may have been undergoing
other stresses at a site called spruce
treehouse Glowacki has found that some
of the buildings were damaged and
remodeled suggesting a change in
ownership by the time you get to the end
of the 1200s
you have a smaller population but you
also have increasing stresses from the
increasing conflict and violence that's
happening in the region as well as the
drought
that ultimately caused Pueblo people to
want to leave and move the combination
of stresses in the mid to late 1200s was
too much for the ancestral Pueblo so
they left many of them settled to the
south in New Mexico where they rebuilt
their society and their descendants
continued to live today although that
happened so long ago the forces that
made them leave political unrest social
upheaval violence climate change all
those seems so familiar today I think
there's a lot of important lessons for
us to learn by studying the past and
studying how Pueblo people you know
dealt with the the situations that they
had because they were able to overcome a
lot substantially change culturally and
continue today
you